c'est la deuxième partie du procès en
extradition de julian assange qui avait
démarré le 24 février durant une semaine
qui devait reprendre en mai puis a été
reporté pour cause d'épidémie de kovy de
19 à ce 7 septembre et donc le procès va
durer trois semaines il a débuté ce
matin avec une nouvelle arrestation de
julian assange alors qu'il n'a jamais
été libérés ce qui est donc surprenant
cela est relatif au dépôt par
l'accusation étasunienne d'un nouvel
acte d'accusation le 13 août donc il y à
peine trois semaines la défense de
julian assange a donc eu trois semaines
pour peaufiner son argumentaire
évidemment la défense de julian assange
elle plaide le fait que julian assange
est un journaliste et qu'il tombe donc
qu'il peut bénéficier pardon de la
liberté d'expression que garantit le
premier amendement des états unis donc
les débats seront sur cette thématique
là julian assange est il un journaliste
est-il un espion c'est la question que
devra trancher la justice britannique
du côté de la défense et des proches de
julian assange
on s'inquiète également de l'état de
santé de julian assange
sa compagne c'était là morice parle à la
vue le voir une seule fois en six mois
et elle a décrit des douleurs intenses
au niveau de son épaule au niveau de sa
cheville il aurait une entorse à la
cheville et ses défenseurs dont nils
melzer le rapporteur spécial de l'onu
sur la torture parle de symptômes qui
révèle une torture psychologique et
d'une détention inhumaine dont on sait
aussi que 216 médecins du monde entier
ont signé une pétition à l'adresse des
autorités britanniques afin de libérer
mes vêtements de julian assange pour
lequel ils craignent des conséquences
sur sa santé irréparable voire même la
mort